I wanted to briefly mention to people
this is an observation I've had I've I
met you I think in 1988 when I was a
punk writer it's airing at live yes
Annelle yeah you get you were part of
the boiler room boys because I called
you yeah yeah you had a room with Smigel
yeah Robert Smigel Craig Daniels Bob
Odenkirk Bob Odenkirk and you yeah yeah
and we killed guys there were there was
some I think a couple of shows I did you
guys got like three pieces on there yeah
we did it was it was a good time and I
remembered always being really excited
when you showed up but you've proven a
theory that I had I noticed it
I think you were one of the first people
that was my first big gig in television
and I remembered every time that you
would host you would stay up practically
all night with the writers I remember at
one point walking through the conference
room at night at like 3:00 in the
morning and you were lying down on the
conference table trying to compose a
sketch now everybody else everybody else
would dip in and dip out and try and
hear what everyone was up to and then
they go off to dinner with Loren and
then maybe they'd come back for a little
bit you were alone in your dedication to
making it a great show more so than more
so than any host while I was there and I
have since told people that you're an
example I think Bruce Springsteen is an
example there's certain people I think
of where it's not an accident this is
someone who is not there are there are
people who accidentally have a great
deal of luck or they're born with you
know well some amazing trick they can do
and then there are just people that have
ability have talent but man I just I
couldn't believe how hard you worked and
well it's they still do that well it's a
great hang I mean I was just trying to
get the hang man you laugh your head off
you know
and the your there is some awfully good
ideas but you know part of it is
associate I couldn't believe I was there
I mean I'm I'm in the world-famous 17th
floor with a conference room and the
whole bit
you wanted to I wanted to soak that up
that was uh what I'm gonna hey Lauren's
a fascinating guy
yeah but after a while I don't need more
Bob Hope stories at dinner you know I
love to compare notes with him as much
as anybody else but eventually you know
the same exact mini anecdote plays
itself my favorite game with Lauren is
is which Paul is he talking about
is it sigh I'm in her McCartney and so
I'd literally played this game I so far
they with him you go you know Paul
called and I go okay dad that's that
could go either way and he's gonna come
by and he might bring his guitar and be
like that doesn't help angry at his
partner doesn't help still do you
haven't had the qualifier yet to talk
that much about the 60s although he'll
play that stuff still but he wants to do
the later stuff still can't do it I'm
gonna see him at the Hamptons still
won't do it you know you just I think
I've been through 45 different
combination locks it's like opening that
box in The Da Vinci Code where it's like
no this doesn't get me there I still
don't know and you know well how much
how much do you sort of like relive in
the same way like Ernie Banks relives
you know ballgames at Wrigley Field
regarding uh Sanel I mean you were there
for a substantial amount of time every
era of SNL is historic in its own way
yeah and every era had some imprint on
comedy and popular culture that was
there it I was affair at a very
fortuitous time because I was there with
the you know Lovitz Dana Carvey Kevin
Nealon Jan hooks
Nora Dunn Norah Don just great great
cast but then Mike Meyer showed up while
I was there you know it and things just
Chris Rock showed up while I was there
and it just kept Adam Sandler's showed
up while I was there so it really was
this golden time to be on Serna live but
I have to tell you absolute great
memories but also almost PTSD well yeah
a lot of nervous breakdowns a lot of
Machiavellian stabs in the back a lot of
disappointments a lot of how did this
happen a lot of four o'clock in the
morning everyone else is behind a closed
door laughing with other people writing
the greatest sketch in the world and I
don't have an idea and I just I'm
wandering the halls and this is when I
would I use to wander down to 6a which
unbeknownst to me would later become my
studio at the time it was Dave's studio
Wow yeah and I would sit behind there
was a cloth that they draped over
Dave's desk which ended up being right
where my desk was for 16 years and I
would sit behind that desk and try and
write sometimes behind his desk on the
late night in on The Late Night with
David Letterman studio I just was and
I'd be in total a dread that is hard for
me to explain to anybody when you don't
have an idea or you have an idea and you
don't think it's good enough and so and
also two of my moments of absolute fear
were on camera and they were with you
drew one was that one of the first big
things I did on TV was a sketch where
you did a monologue about how people say
on the nicest guy in the world but I'm
really not it's just you know it's it's
ridiculous it's not true and I'm tired
of this Tom Hanks's the nicest guy in
the world it's just not true now if
you'll excuse me a minute and then you
walk off and the camera follows you live
and you could you remember this you
perform all these miracles yeah yes
you're crazy like you had the line stay
away from this horse mr. Hanks he bites
and I cut it and say no he's just a
misunderstood creature like that
no I am waiting and this is live and you
have no idea what it's like it I mean
you do but I'm talking to the tubes
people listen to this podcast the fear
of you're a punk kid and at some
point Tom Hanks is gonna come by the
opening of the show which at the time is
watched by you know a million eight
billion people yelling people lie and
Tom Hanks is gonna come by and my job
was to stand there holding the horse and
then my line was you go ah look at that
guy and I go oh don't touch him mr.
Hanks that horse bites everyone can you
go nonsense he's just a misunderstood
creature and you pet him and I go wow so
you're coming and I just keep repeating
my line oh and of course I'm doing the
thing we all do when we're in our heads
too much don't bite that horse Hank's no
talk don't Tom the Hanks wait don't bite
that
and while I'm trying to do it you know
who the musical guest was that week of
course you don't Aerosmith nope no it
was a newly solo Keith Richards with my
God with the expensive winos yeah that's
right yes Richards was at was at the
crafts food service table next to me
right bring pixie boots and he chooses
that time while you're walking towards
me you have about four interactions that
you have to have before you get to me
and he goes AUSA's right and I'm just
going like what and I'd love to talk to
Keith Richards but not now you know what
anyway it was everything like he was
explaining how man did it on literally
on the backs of horses and he thought
that I was the guy who owned the horse
and I almost said to him shut the
up Keith Richards and your idea is
Tom Hanks is on his way and
I've got to do so I said ed my line
and the other one was the first five
timers Club sketch oh that was a biggie
yeah I'm Sean and you come in the door
and I'm supposed to put a robe on you
and I'll never forget you come in the
door and all I have to do you go hello
Sean I got mr. Hanks is take a silk robe
and put it on you first
first silk robe catches on you can see
Italy you have this habit online yeah
yeah you can see it I'm having a second
and it's just a millisecond but for me I
saw my entire life flash before my eyes
cuz I thought if I can't get this jacket
off I'm dead I'm dead forever
but I get it off and then I go to put it
on you and one of the sleeves sleeves
was inside out yeah you remember this
yeah you've probably been angry about it
oh no I
I never saw it after it aired so I was
never bother look at it